analyzing data is like cooking you pick
your datasets with ingredients you clean
them you slice them and then you serve
your results I'm Felipe Hoffa and in
this video I am going to travel to dress
and Germany to meet the team fighting
spam abdomen Levu is unreliability up
and their engineers use data to identify
and block spammers trying to abuse their
system in this episode we are going to
learn how they define features to train
a logistic regression model to find Pusa
spammer and now they can do all of this
inside the world and because we love
food we are going to do all these while
cooking
[Music]
here we have 20 real Santa's one of the
Big Data engineers fighting spam from
local Suckley so hi everyone my name is
Juan and I'm one of the artists farmers
here at Lu and my role here is to design
and to develop new techniques an
algorithm to D take less farmer on our
platform and to avoid the proliferation
of them so today since we're going to be
talking about span I thought that the
most ideal thing would be to cook
something with spam
so I'm going to be preparing one typical
dish from my country Porto Rico which is
called spam Quezada or just simply
Harmonia I'm getting hanged already it's
really important to know what exactly
spammer and normal users are doing
because of course are going to behave in
different ways for example spammers they
- normally the same action quite often
and normal users will they just act
normal so the tracer has three different
kind of actions we have what is called
the active action which are the thing
the user is doing for example I like you
I send you one message and then we also
have the passive action which are the
thing that you are doing upon me you are
sending me one message you are liking me
and then we have the time which is the
how much time it has been between each
different action
you have your whole system processing
images processing events and you're also
using bigquery I would love to know how
you use bigquery we use bigquery mostly
for sorting our data you know for
studying our historical data prediction
data training set and so on however
recently we started to use bigquery to
do machine learning on it
can you show me what are your tables how
do you do my dear learning inside the
query right let's get on it
so first here we have our data set and
inside I will tell I said we have one
small group of tables which I'll call
the sample tables and in these sample
tables I'm gonna keep just that your
small sample tiny versions of our big
data set so here let's take a look at
what I call the sheriff Jerry is one of
our machine learning models and this one
is going to predict if you are a spammer
or not based on the thing that you're
doing and some of the characteristic of
your profiles and here we have to the
residue we had the training one and the
testing one that's right anyone of
course if we for training the system and
the testing one is for testing
yeah and here each column represent our
features unfortunately I need to hye-sun
of them so that's why you only see
numbers but however we can focus on the
one called message sent light unlike
creative and this is saying just that
these are the messages that I sent to
you these are the lights that I have
done to others and the people that have
liked me which is row
yeah like here we shall represent one
observation so when you sir when you say
yeah each user just summarized features
so here so like I said this dataset this
train is actually made of two different
things the first one is what are you
doing what we calculate this by looking
at the ratio of execution of events
meaning value of all the events that you
have done what is the percentage of
message sent and in this case we have
one user our user number five and we can
see that the value is around thirty nine
percent meaning that of all the event
the person have done thirty nine percent
of them has been message sir nice these
features in like experimenting yes like
I mean you try with two you try with
that you'll lose some you gain some you
know just a matter of experimentation
[Music]
how do you train this how do you
determine how do I train this well we
have our features or I mean the big
query feature of how to do machine
learning inside the query and first we
need to go to our query editor of course
huh and then we're going to execute our
query and here we have this kind of
simple query and it's called create or
replace and this is going to be exactly
that is going to create one model or in
case the model already exists is going
to replace it cool what what are your
options here my options so first the
first one the most important one is our
model type which is what kind of mode
that I want to Train in this case I want
to use logistic regression allows you to
to do binary classification either 0 or
1 through or false hammer or hammer oh
yeah like that's how we call that that
way you say I want to get exactly the
others the second one is input label
combs and here we specify which is the
column that is our target in this case
going to be spam so I also have mass
iteration and this one it says 250 and
this means that my system is going to
train for 50 iterations normally in this
case is no longer that's not necessary
because I'm really curious in certain
five or six howevers for the next part I
want to show you how the last function
decrease and for that I'm setting goes
to 50 so we can have more data so we can
see a prettier curve also for that we
need to set early stop to false really
important otherwise I'm just going to
stop early so let's start training this
model
[Music]
we have getting some results at least so
far since we use much iteration of 50 we
are currently on iteration number 41 EMC
is taking around six to seven seconds to
actually for each iteration so it's
quite fast however we can realize here
that the training loss is not changing
much however like I said before I was
expecting this I just want to have 50
duration just to see how the loss
function looks like because I just like
to visualize things how would you like
this well let's do it in the studio one
of my favorite official dances of
bigquery is that we had this cool bottom
here really powerful bottom which is
called exploring data studio and when
you click there is it going to kind of
migrate to tell your whole Jerez that
I'm just going to move it to a new data
studio window and here in the studio
then we can visualize our data cool so
you can just now select from whatever
the the training yeah yeah and then we
can get this data out into data studio
exactly and here this is how it looks to
me first we need to move from bottom see
here and drag and drop but essentially
this is how the y-axis we have the loss
it's like we had the loss and then in
the x-axis we had a number of iteration
and here like expected once again in our
own interaction of five or four their
values was already kind of getting to
star more stable pretty low and then you
get to a minimum of like between one
point to maybe a lot maybe like point
fifteen point fourteen that's pretty
good I'm pretty fast oh oh by the way
now you get these visualizations
automatically inside the query when the
training is done we can also look at the
stats of this model yeah this is
actually pretty cool so you know that to
make sure I mean if you want to know
what the model is either good or not
then we need to have some matrix and
here we have all the five or six metrics
just out of the box we don't have to
calculate anything and for example we
can see precision recall accuracy F
one's called the lock function I mean
the loss function that we just saw and
the area under the curve and by just
looking at this value I will say that is
pretty good you know we have an accuracy
of own
of 96% our f1 score is almost 92 on the
area under the curve I wouldn't say it's
really excellent yeah once you have your
whole model trained what's behind the
model what's behind them all the sort in
this case is what you see majestic
regressions basically we have a bunch of
things we called the weight or the
coefficient which if I explain quicker
on a steel or disintegrate rings
basically one huge mathematical equation
with a lot of different values and this
values is actually what we're going to
learn during training so at the end of
the day all this fancy thing just
transforms into a couple of numbers you
know like our coefficients and they
intercept and with this equal function
we can get our weights out actually good
question yes if we would like to
implement this in production into
another system that we just only need to
export all of these values and that we
should build the equation ourself and
then just by plugging in the values per
funda we have our model well this is
really great because basically you gave
me query this is my table these are my
label exactly and just ran logistic
regression yeah and you've got a lot of
these yes automatically and that's one
way in which lure identifies the spam
online-dating spam now with the query
it's really easy to start iterating the
features and the training of your mother
without leaving the data warehouse but
dinner is not ready until we serve it
how do we know how well that the spam
team is doing our Levu let's go back to
the kitchen serving here in this game
would be of course to serve the mother
in production however more than that I
need to make sure how the model is
performing you know I want to know how
our results are about doing this so we
have some no numbers here these are from
our transparency error reports and
basically this is some report that we do
where we polish we make public all these
values you know so people can have an
idea of how our system is performing and
in the third quarter of 2016 our
percentages panel was only 0.3% meaning
that of all our user we only have point
three percent of them were actually
Spanish so it's less than 1% and
number is quite stable as we can see
here as I point three point two and so
on and I give the number being stable
it's a huge accomplishment it's good you
know because it means down is never
going to drop to zero of course but it's
actually if the number keeps stable if
the number doesn't grow it means that
we're doing a good job that's all I
think this but I I guess as farmers keep
finding new ways to yes actually it's an
eternal fight like if I sleep if I get
sloppy or anything then they would just
go go ahead keeping them yeah and the
yet another metric that I really like to
see is the one that say the time it
takes to punish someone because of
course we are real time and we want to
get the person now so on at the
beginning again in the third quarter of
2016 we had around 2.2 hours
after that the number went down and then
after that we had a huge drop sorry when
he went from point two from two point
one to one point one that's like an hour
left and then suddenly do something that
happens you know like news family words
or so on and then the number increase
and then after that is going downtown
okay yeah that's a huge drop at the end
well done with that thank you so as we
serve our results in a dashboard and we
publish how good you'll be doing
throughout this year and this is
basically the end of our process once
you have anything running you can
visualize it you can show everyone how
well you're doing and once your dish is
ready you can serve it like here you go
thank you I hope you enjoy it I can find
some spam here and I'm glad that you
taught me how to find the spam maybe I'm
glad I had this opportunity to talk to
you about anti spam bigquery machine
learning and most importantly about how
we fight our stars and that was really
cool a lot thanks to you enjoy now I'll
do the same I had so much fun making
this video thanks a lot to Lagoon
200 EOS and to you for watching should I
do more of this please leave me a
message and let me know what would you
like to cook thank you very much I'm
Felipe Hoffa and remember to subscribe
[Music]